is your mom or dad like who who has your
kind of energy
um I would say my dad but my mother we
find out now also like with strength
like uh she unfortunately she has a
stroke and she's in a special place but
her grip like if she grabs a bar then
you know you're gonna need a screwdriver
in order to reply yeah like she's
incredibly strong with that no I don't
you have a group as well or no no no no
no especially this hand this had this
like at fortnite surgeries so if you see
this you can tell see the whole biceps
atrophied here how many surgeries you
said four got it I could have pulled the
trigger from a gun that's how weak my
hand was so once I get my hand back
I was uh I said okay I'm I stopped
complaining now but what I used to push
myself through it is that I have this
eczema everywhere I would make a face
that password it was disgusting you know
I had to wear gloves the whole time long
sleeve still collection but
um I always knew and that I did this as
a kid that there are people way worse
they have that what I have on my hands
their entire body my asthma attack I had
for a week I knew that there were people
who had the 365 days a year see compared
to them it wasn't that bad this is how I
always work my problems boss how big is
your hands can you put your hands here
like your fingers those are your fingers
are long yeah you got some yeah so it's
interesting your fingers are super long
yeah but then this part of your hand
Palm is small fingers are long yeah so
it's good for a grip because you can go
around very interesting yeah yeah did
you did you did you see that I see how
big his hands are yes I don't know but
but this is this part is small the
fingers are long so you can grip
oh my God please
this one E.T over here
I just noticed that right now wait a
minute what was that all about yeah I
would do that and then because as a guy
would do this and it would first be
angry I go dude I'm doing this to make
you laugh and then it would start
laughing you know so there's no fights
boss I never in a million years did I
Envision doing this
but now that I'm doing this and seeing
your face
your dad I wonder so your mom's grip you
said your dad was an energy guy was he a
fighter or no not really athlete World
track and field guys I was going to be
actually the next Bruce Jenner that was
my I wanted to be Kathleen I was going
Bruce not Kyle it's going to be Bruce
not Caitlyn yeah no at the time he was
the 7th Street School I remember I met
him I met him yeah yeah so I wanted to
do a decathlon that was going hard on my
way you know I was doing really well in
the track and field needs to say my my
running times were always the worst
because of my asthma but for the rest
everything I was pretty good so got it
so there was some genetics that came
your parents mom yeah got strength and
that so with all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks bright if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red are black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks bad toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]